not only did kim kardashian and pete
davidson make their red carpet debut at
the white house correspondents dinner
over the weekend the 28 year old
comedian also debuted some new ink that
fans speculate is a tribute to the 41
year old reality star and her four
kiddos so we'll just have to wait and
see
right over the weekend pete was spotted
with kim in la sporting a new tat that
reads kn scp and now fans are theorizing
the k stands for kim
while the other letters stand for the
children kim shares with her estranged
husband kanye west north saint chicago
and psalm
and while we'll just have to wait and
see if the saturday night livestar
confirms the meaning behind that fresh
ink we do know that it wouldn't be his
first tattoo dedicated to the skim's
founder i don't know how you're gonna
top that back in march kim revealed that
not only does her boyfriend have a few
tattoos dedicated to her i think my
favorite one
it says here it says my girl is a lawyer
and that one's really cute he also has
her name branded on his chest yeah you
heard me not tattooed
branded he was like i want something
that's there that i can't you know get
rid of he's like i don't want to be able
to get rid of it or to cover it up and i
just wanted it like there as like a scar
on me
meanwhile a source recently told et that
the two are in a great place in their
relationship adding that she is so happy
he's just super genuine
and it's just really fun to just
hang out and do nothing and
watch tv and just do nothing
and according to e.t source her famous
family loves him too and she feels light
and fun when she's around him which
echoes what the kardashian crew told et
last month i love that he's kind
and really really thoughtful he's the
most thoughtful person
and i love yeah and i love the chemistry
that kim and him have together it's
really sweet she said the chemistry it's
like okay chemistry
chemistry
[Music]
you